my channel is sponsored by Alienware
which means we'll have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of today's video
hello everyone I'm Milan and welcome to
my gaming channel where today we're
talking about Oppenheimer I guess we
talk about movies now I don't know I'm
enjoying it they're so much shorter than
video games it's so much easier to
review them I'm also seeing Barbie this
weekend so we'll talk about Bobby but uh
right now I am fresh off the heels of
seeing Oppenheimer in IMAX here in La as
God intended God or Christopher Nolan
whichever you prefer and there is a lot
to unpack
this is a three hour movie with
absolutely no fat uh there is so much to
cover and frankly the first thing I want
to say is that I wish I could see it
twice and because of that it's like okay
these are my first impressions but I
would really love to sit with this one
for a bit longer I am also definitely a
big Chris Nolan fan uh I think Dunkirk
is probably my favorite of his films but
yeah definitely aware that there's like
a couple of biases going in here uh
where you know this movie is very hyped
and to lean into that it is an absolute
master class in filmmaking and my
biggest takeaway is that I am so glad
that Christopher Nolan exists as a
person who so clearly cares about every
aspect of Cinema of filmmaking and is
also right now where so much of the
world is like groveling for comic book
IP able to actually be given the budget
to take these risks and make these films
um seemingly exactly how he intends to
with very little corporate oversight
it's it's incredible the edit the sound
design the production value there are
almost no VFX here I mean they detonated
a real bomb especially after the last
two movies that I reviewed uh on here
were the Flash and Indiana Jones have
some of the worst deep fake Tech I've
ever seen the aging and de-aging in uh
Oppenheimer is perfect because it's
practical but like the sound design oh
my God that's something that I just I
could gush over forever there's just so
many positive things to say about it
um but then speaking of bias I will also
mention my own personal bias going into
this one because I do have one and I
want to mention it
because I suspect that other people
might have the same bias as me so it'll
inform how you feel about this
potentially I am personally very
interested in Oppenheimer
as a human when I joined Sony Santa
Monica in 2020 for anyone who doesn't
know that's the studio known for making
the God of War video game series
one of the first tasks I took on was
actually uh a very big deep dive into
Brock and sindri how they may have felt
about mjolnir and Thor and ultimately
ended up trying to liken them to
Oppenheimer whether that's reflected in
anything you've seen of God of War is
inconsequential it's just a thing that I
did and I studied it for a really long
time and I studied him and I got so
fascinated with how you feel when you've
made the weapon to end all weapons when
you've made the atomic bomb there is a
world before the atomic bomb was made
and there is a world afterwards and
oppenheimer's regrets in the Manhattan
Project and how he spoke about all of
that is super interesting and something
that again I just find so fascinating
that I wish it were the climax of the
film but it kind of isn't I feel like
the movie should have really revolved
around the bomb and like cut very
cleanly with the devastation of that but
I also think that it did a very good job
of delving a bit further than that into
the political landscape of the time so
much reference to Communism in this
movie which is a thing and it was a very
big deal about whether Oppenheimer was
part of the Communist Party the film
does really deal with the political
landscape of the time and how scientists
were viewed at the time and
um I think it does a great job of that
and builds its own tension within that
it's just not necessarily the climax
I've wanted personal bias preference
again one I think a few people might
agree with me on I'll get into more
specifics later so the things that this
movie does well my god there are so many
this film is so Snappy in terms of
editing that um it just whizzes by it's
three hours long and feels like it's two
it doesn't drag in any way whatsoever
and at first I wasn't sure how I felt
about that until it really sat with me
that part of the speed is tension and
and anxiety
um and very directly clearly mimics kind
of the tone of the time which was uh a
tremendous period of scientific
discovery very rapidly a race between
mean the Germans The Americans
and the Russians in this particular
scientific academic field obviously the
very rapid progress of the war
and Oppenheimer is effectively existing
in that world at that pace
um with all of the pressures of several
countries his people being the Jewish
people
against a race of an anti-semitic Army
obviously so at first I was like whoa
this is so quick what the heck and then
it it felt it ended up just feeling like
a masterful editing choice
with the way that it very well I think
reflects the way Oppenheimer is feeling
this movie very much is inside of his
head it's a journey you are being taken
along with him he's very rarely not in a
scene and you get context of important
parts of his backstory it's it's very
much like a biopic more than a character
study though I would say they have
clearly made sure to be um authentic
legitimate honest
where the actual history is regarding
which I think is very important it's a
very important thing to not to realize
so yeah editing
unbelievably fast but in a way that I
think serves the overall thesis of the
movie very very well it's just really
unusual it's really unique and it's time
to talk about the Alienware M18 gaming
laptop which is alienware's most
powerful laptop yet and if I'm being
honest I also think the single most
powerful gaming laptop I've ever even
heard of so if you're in the market for
portable gaming without losing any
quality listen to this the Alienware M18
features 13th generation Intel core
processors Nvidia GeForce RTX 40 series
graphics and enhanced Alienware cryotech
for improved Cooling and airflow it has
an expansive 18 inch display panel and
RGB perky Cherry MX mechanical keyboard
with a numpad and a variety of SSD
options for more internal storage it
also features the new Alienware Legend
3.0 design with smooth rounded edges and
Stadium Lighting on the back of the
laptop and if you're an Nvidia fan like
I am you will be thankful for the Nvidia
GeForce rtx40 series Graphics feature
technology like Ray tracing and deep
learning super sampling or dlss3 Ray
tracing allows you to experience
textures complex lighting and the most
realistic in-game environments to create
the ultimate immersive gaming experience
but any way you want it's a laptop so
it's on the go and dlss3 observes how a
game uses motion and then uses AI to
create free frames that improve FPS and
performance essentially reducing strain
on your GPU and CPU games can run
smoother and with higher frame rates so
if you are in the market for gaming on
the go without losing any of the quality
check out the Alienware mat the second
thing I want to call out is the
performances across the board goddamn
fantastic
um I think kylian Murphy as Oppenheimer
obviously his eyes play very strongly
into it they have very similar eyes
and I think that that is uh very
powerful in this case weird thing to say
when it's aesthetic rather than his
actual performance but you'll see what I
mean when you see it if you haven't
already I think that because of the way
that it's kind of told a little bit more
like a biopic and less of a character
study there are probably a few moments
where we could have had a little more of
his Humanity we don't see a lot of him
interacting with his kids for example
there are definitely some romantic
conflicts and some interpersonal
struggles but um mostly we are seeing an
academic pursue academics that could
have been a little bit more Humanity in
there though I don't know where the
you would have put it fitted in when
this movie's again so fast-paced the
rest of the cast across the board
incredible um in fact the only character
uh maybe performance I don't know it's
hard to say that I didn't like was
Florence Pugh which seems crazy because
she's like one of my favorite actresses
right now very big fan of Florence Pugh
love her as a person and an actress from
what I know I just felt like her
character was very
lacking Humanity feels like the right
way to put it out of a very film auteur
thing in terms of writing where she
didn't speak like a real human she spoke
like a character who was written and
sometimes that works in these kinds of
settings but which is kind of a letdown
for me literally everybody else across
the board fantastic probably Matt
Damon's best performance yet Robert
Downey Jr's best performance yet
engrossing complex characters people I
don't know what you're supposed to call
them here across the board so many names
introduced but very easy to follow who
is who which I feel like is really easy
to lose especially with how quickly they
are all introduced and what they're
doing and what they're in just my God
which I guess is where we get into the
script as mentioned could have used some
more Humanity in a couple of cases I
don't know where you would fit it in
though the script is so radic though
because it jumps between so many
different places timelines people and
yet still so succinctly introduces
personal drama and Stakes without ever
over explaining anything it I would love
to read it an expert job of telling you
who you should trust and why and when
including some slips there are people
that you shouldn't trust that
Oppenheimer initially does trust there
are people that Oppenheimer hates that
you should disagree with him on hating
that he changes his mind on while it is
his journey and is you know through his
lens it's not asking you to agree with
him on everything and that is also a
thing that I think is very difficult to
do especially in a story where you are
repeatedly being told that Oppenheimer
is a prophet is a word used at one point
and that is definitely a bit of a
tell-not show um but I think that that
works here they most often tell you that
everyone thinks he's a God but because
the film is mostly from his perspective
you're not seeing that much of that
you're aware that people say it to him
uh you see some of his arrogance in
little short tiny bits of dialogue where
he doesn't have to tell you I think I'm
the best it's just a quippy dismissal
not even quippy that's not the right
word just a smart dismissal questioning
very just expert script in how quickly
it tells you who everyone is Oppenheimer
says this is who this person is figure
it out the bits of exposition that do
exist
um are quite small and the weaker Parts
really even if one of them is
technically like 100 historically
accurate I think almost verbatim in some
cases they're just like two uh
characters that is like mini plot twist
that I didn't feel like uh paid off as
much as they might like to have had
considering the scale of the film again
you have these these two instances of
betrayal or deception trickery whatever
that
couldn't dream of having as much impact
as the bomb being set off and the world
reacting to it and thus uh just kind of
complicate things a little rather than
enrich
um but very minor criticism production
design set design costume design all of
that this movie is going to be so
awarded for just the attention to detail
again even the thing that I wish were a
little different which is like end on
the bomb and the after effects of the
bomb and Oppenheimer himself mentally
um instead of like kind of the pot where
it splits to become two separate movies
and where I would have focused the
interview segments on like how he felt a
little more than they did and less on
whether he deserves security clearance
or new people who are in the Communist
Party those were very important like
news headline making pieces of the
Oppenheimer story that Chris Nolan's
done given a lot of respect to it's also
got this like I said the editing is
tension
the sound design there is this this way
that they
Express a lot of the anxiety that
Oppenheimer must be feeling that I think
is like brilliant like I was in a sense
of awe they're repeating this thing
that's almost like a timey why me thing
like you find out where a noise comes
from later and it plays at moments where
the whole world is really on his
shoulders the initial race to get this
bomb made before the Nazis do and how
important that is not only for him
personally but obviously for the entire
world and the history of mankind and
then the bomb goes off and how he feels
about the reception to that and and how
lauded he is in comparison to how he
actually feels about what he's done and
then being questioned about what he's
done and how he feels about it and and
that overwhelming sense of panic the way
that they display that Panic not through
this straight laced very calm
outwardly appearing calm man but through
sound design and
um probably not VFX I don't even really
know what the word is like artistic
expression they basically just like hint
at anxiety and PTSD I think in a really
specific way that's just so impactful
especially the way it recurs and I think
that covers most of everything that I
really liked and the tiny little things
I didn't love so much about it without
spoilers I think it's so hard to say
because again the movie's massive and
there's so much happening and I feel
very strongly about so much of it so
we're gonna get into spoilers here so I
can delve a little bit more deeply into
my main criticism so spoilers Beyond
this point weird thing to say about a
historically accurate film I know you
ready for spoilers talking about
spoilers
spoilers now so this thing I've been
dancing around which is uh the worst
thing that's been in any Nolan film ever
I don't know why they did it
um oh my God the very famous quote from
Oppenheimer uh where he said you know he
created the atomic bomb and was reminded
of a quote which is I am become death
the destroyer of worlds it's just a real
obvious way that you are going to say
that a very great place to say it would
be after letting the bomb off I don't
know if this actually happened but from
everything I know about Oppenheimer it
did not so this is not historically
accurate unless I'm missing that
somewhere and I just never came across
any of my research somehow
um he says it while having sex
he says it well before making the bomb
well
um just somebody and she's like
read this line of this book and holds it
while on top of him and he goes I am
become death the destroyer of worlds
while they're there are like
artsy fartsy excuses for this you could
very easily be like oh mankind
reproduction and he's gonna go on and
she's gonna kill herself because she
kills herself at the end of the movie
actually it's much more heavily implied
that she is murdered they don't actually
know
she was killed almost definitely but
that like you know her being part of his
whole cycle and part of the Communist
party and them having sex and her ending
up dead for him to be able to create the
atomic bomb you can make the case for
the whole Loop of all of that coming
back around into a human moment but my
god did you ruin one of the most
impactful historically relevant lines
like of all King time just cheapened the
value of that line by so much I'm very
curious to see if I will be alone in my
take care Oh another thing I really
wanted to give a um a thing that I
really really loved while we're in the
spoiler territory still the relationship
and conversations with Albert Einstein
is this part where uh Robert Downey Jr's
character is still feels weird to call
them characters but that's the easiest
way to relate to an audience I think is
convinced that Oppenheimer has turned
Einstein against him and he's criticized
someone's like what if they weren't even
talking about you and they won't and it
in the end reveals the conversation they
actually had which was about you know
the impact of being a man of creation
and I thought that was so beautiful we
actually finally got to see that
conversation after it being like kind of
teased and made a mystery throughout the
film again a little bit hurt by it being
the climax where the climax still should
have been the bomb
but um that I really really really loved
felt very Inception actually in a funny
way to like learn what that conversation
actually was what they actually spoke
about and how much importance was put on
that conversation by the uh by Strauss
uh Robert Downey Jr's part but yeah my
ultimate takeaway is that I really want
to see it again
that I think it is a standout in
filmmaking
and that I wish it had done you know a
couple of things a little differently
one thing a little differently but I
also get why it didn't it makes a lot of
sense I just really want to see it again